so why did you choose fun to anything
over Kickstarter well um a friend of
mine who is working for fund anything
approached me about doing a campaign
over there and I didn't really you know
I was probably like most of the world
like kind of heard about the idea of
crowdfunding like in the back of your
ear and what it was and but I had no
idea what the specifics that were or
anything so I did I listened to what he
had to say I did a little research with
IndieGoGo and Kickstarter which and I
found them all pretty having similar
platforms but since my friend kind of
personally drew me in to find anything I
found myself a kind of more attracted to
them because it would seem more personal
but then they I mean I don't have a
really other experience with
crowdfunding sites but they were so
involved they helped us out they got on
the phone with us they work things out
they told us when they thought things
weren't good and I heard from other
people that Kickstarter and IndieGoGo
they just kind of like but you out there
hope you make it you know so I really
appreciated the personal attention from
then they're really lovely people and
they're trying to do something which I
think all of them are there trying to
help artists in this kind of know
artists help society to be really
eloquent about it they're trying to do
something to make the public aware you
know I was talking about everybody
becoming this patron of their of the
Arts you know and we need this in the
country can't just be about like you
know texting and video games and what
you can watch on iTunes I mean it's just
the world has gotten to be this like you
know very it's like dulling itself
around the edges I think and if we're
going to do stuff to shake it up again I
think the people need to get involved
and what they like and what they can see
and they can support and they can
override this kind of no no no no no
society no that's too much of a risk no
that's too thing no it's about a woman
no that's did you know that the people
holding the purse strings you know so
it's like I've been looking for this
revolution for a long time and I think
this is you know I don't think
Kickstarter
I mean I don't think crowdfunding is the
end-all of what it but I think it's an
option and I think it's a great option
but i think it's an enormous amount of
work and it's a real kind of trial by
error thing the first time you do it
because who could you know i'm a 40-plus
year old woman's that wasn't really my
generational thing but at the same time
now i know and i'm part of that new
generation and I know what it is and I'm
not just like oh turn down the beers
like it's too loud you know like you
know because but you know what I mean
it'sit's see you become involved with
stuff and you know about it and that
that way you stay in touch with this new
generation you don't necessarily have to
use it all the time but instead of kind
of closing yourself off to the future or
the present you become a part of it and
I think there's you know and I think
there's an incredible generosity this
incredible support from people who are
interested you know in you or you know
and say things and kind of either
support you or give money to you or just
to look and see what you're doing and I
think that there's something you know
very you know warm about it in a way you
know that that's not so warm sometimes
when you're looking for money other ways
what were some of the things that they
told you at fund anything like did they
give you a list of bullet points of do's
and don'ts but he did they did and you
know of course you know being the rebel
that I am like I'm not doing this and
I'm not gonna do this and I'm doing this
this way you know and they're like okay
are you want to do but then at the end
I'm like okay that's not working what
should I do and they were like well okay
and they helped out and so that's great
you know I'm tend to be a very like you
know I guess when you come from
independent cinema and you're the
youngest child you end up like never
asking anybody for help I'm very bad at
asking people for help and this was the
ultimate ask for help you know putting
yourself out there putting yourself on
lines a very vulnerable thing to do in a
way but it helped me get over like those
kind of fears about it you know whether
you completely succeed or crash and burn
you have to do something it's like a
call to action you
no I'm making a movie with a basically
an unknown actress I'm making a movie
about something they can't figure out
were like how to financially make it
like is that going to be successful you
know there's a lot of making about
Hollywood I'm making you know and it's
just kind of its kind of scathing and so
there's all these things like completely
like people aren't really like oh great
so I mean I like a challenge but I think
this is what I want to do and I think
Alexia is the best person for the job
and so doing this crowdfunding and
stating it out there in the world
doesn't allow someone to say oh who else
you could use this star instead of her
or you can do it's like this is what I'm
doing you like it go for it you don't
like it that's okay movies aren't made
for everyone but this is what I'm doing
and don't change it and so I finally got
to find my voice and be very strong in
my voice and what I wanted out of it so
I felt that that was you know that all
different kinds of things came out of
just going into the action of this
crowdfunding which I thought was really
really interesting and motivating and
telling what were some surprises i mean
i know you have four days left as of the
taping of this video what were some
surprises that you you weren't aware of
either positive negative whatever just
epiphanies you had about this whole
process well hey what's really sweet
about like the funding is like people
come out of the woodwork that you
wouldn't expect to and it's psych the
most touching thing you could ever see
in your life you know like my accountant
or the guy my dry cleaner or something
like they know me and they have a
relationship mean they want to see me
succeed and I just think that that kind
of thing is like you shake your head
like y pedir away from your eye because
you don't it's unexpected you know and
so there's things like that and and it's
like you know I'm kind of not the most i
mean i'll do the social network i just
don't know if I'm doing it right you
know so there's but there's a lot of
contact with people and with different
people reaching out from different areas
of filmmaking to fans to friends and so
you start to readjust have a
reconnection with people and
gosh you know I've been living in Paris
for the last six years and I felt a
little bit off the grid coming back to
America I got to be honest you know and
so it was a great way of remembering and
reconnecting and becoming becoming part
of society again in this kind I mean it
is a strange society the people belong
to and instead of being always on the
outside like I'm to indy year I'm tube
is or I don't need to talk to anyone
it's like no I need to talk to a lot of
people and I need to keep talking to a
lot of people for business for
motivation for food like you know
intellectual food and so being someone
that doesn't like to ask for help and I
know that affliction very much how do
you get to cross out of that comfort
zone where you do because crowdfunding
is so much about I don't know I don't
even remember how I got I just remember
starting to prepare for crowdfunding and
not really questioning it and then all
of a sudden I was i I was so nervous
excuse me I was so nervous on the first
day I was like I was like Cathy he know
that cartoon would like the tears coming
into my eyes like oh I don't know what
to do and you know is on I didn't you
know spontaneously combust that day no
one you know threw stones at me I lived
through that day and others and so you
know I I think in this world I was
thinking about it the other day it's
like you don't know how to do anything
without practicing and you know you
can't be good anything without
practicing how to do it in honing your
skills on any every level you know
including asking for help so sometimes
you need to get thrown in the pool in
order to figure out you know how to deal
with it and how to ask for something and
you know I get so frustrated cuz I might
not and then someone said well you don't
ask for anything how does anyone know
that you need help and I thought you
know so you know you're constantly
working on yourself trying to figure out
how to
get better at stuff you know
you